à nos deux manches bonjour jours merci
d'être avec nous sur le jeu dur ben
c'est un grand plaisir
donc on va vous consacrez un vie parce
que pour plusieurs raisons d'abord parce
que vous à thiviers noir et deuxio
puisque vous avez une belle actualité à
savoir un spectacle en ce moment je veux
jouer à pas ce oui tout ça c'est bon
jusque là sans faute jusque là tout va
bien
donc j'aimerais qu'on remonte un tout
petit peu en avant donc comment vous est
venue cette idée de cette vocation
d'humoriste par exemple ça vient de tout
petit déjà vraiment tout petit ouej les
premiers sketchs que j'ai joués je les
ai joués en cp j'écoutais les cassettes
de variétés qui avait à la maison mais
par enregistré à la télé je reproduisais
en fait j'allais dans la cour de récré
je faisais du raymond devos du coluche
et desproges et tout ça à mes copains
qui comprenait rien évidemment qu'ils
comprenaient pas mal je récitais ces
trucs-là parker mais voilà ça a été le
mon premier contact
avec ça de vrai mais je j'ai commencé
tout gamin à m'intéresser à ça et puis
après j'ai découvert airs et chansons et
ça a été la mine d'or et je n'ai plus
jamais voulu faire autre chose d'accord
la vie et vous parle on était content
mes parents ça allait encore c'est à
saint jean de béthune à versailles oui
vraiment là ils ouvraient des hurons
quand est-ce qu'ils ont l'un disait oui
je le disais ouais je quand on met ma
fiche d'orientation sous le nez qu'est
ce que voulait faire plus tard je
m'étais humoristes ou comique à city
serait interrogé disons que j'ai à dire
et dès que possible en fait j'étais
j'étais convoqué on m'expliquait que
fallait choisir un vrai métier mais pour
moi c'était déjà un vrai métier il y
avait des gens qui passaient à la radio
qu'ils gagnaient leur vie avec ça donc
pourquoi pas moi le sait ça et c'est
tout le thème du spectacle c'est
pourquoi pas moi d'accord et alors donc
juste vous avez fait l'école du rire
alors comment ça se passe c'est ça non
je j'ai fait une école de graphistes
après j'ai travaillé dans la pub et
comme j'en ai eu marre
ouais j'ai voulu travailler dans
l'humour et donc je me suis débrouillé
pour me faire repérer par par des
chaînes de télé des émissions comme on
fait aussi repéré à l'époque moi j'ai
ouvert un blog
je me suis fait passer pour jacques
chirac ah oui effectivement extelia
quand même temps c'était en 2004
donc soit il ya plus de douze ans ouais
et les journalistes y ont cru donc
c'était le blog de jeanne cherhal
c'était jacques chirac points comme
point d'orgue point fr j'avais racheté
les noms de domaine et donc du coup je
m'étais fait passer pour le chef de
l'état qui est à l'époque où il ya déjà
un youtube y avait pas de bleus il n'y
avait pas tous ces trucs là non ça
paraissait très vraisemblable on accordé
une crédibilité dingue alors très
agréable quoi c'est ça mais dsk venait
d'ouvrir le sien alain juppé venait
d'ouvrir le sien y avait un tout petit
effet de début de quelque chose et on
s'était dit pourquoi pas le salaire va
semblables et donc j'ai été une fois que
la supercherie a été découverte et à
l'ami du temps et des copains une
semaine une semaine et demie sur un
temps médiatique c'est infini et larves
racontiez plein de choses je racontais
sa vie à l'elysée mais avec un ton
humoristique et au début s'est passé au
début s'est passé et l'elysée avait une
semaine à démentir un média aujourd'hui
ça mettrait 30 secondes être fermées
ainsi vrai mais à l'époque voilà donc je
lui ai fait je suis le premier humoriste
qui soit sorti d'internet quand même
j'ai sorti ma 40 firmes
c'est pas normal c'est moi sauf que lui
il a réussi mais le
voilà match à cazaux rythme c'est ça
mais bon moi je fais je suis le premier
voile à être sur scène et avoir commencé
par explorer internet pas soumises à la
3ème personne est donc là vous êtes fait
repérer dans mercier repéré par karl
zéro et canal plus qui m'ont engagé et
j'ai travaillé avec eux pendant 4 ou 5
en temps ouattara lors comme auteur
comme chroniqueur comme concepteur de
rubriques démission je travaillais sur
plein de choses avec karl et puis après
j'ai créé avec deux copains les gérard
du cinéma et vos visions et les gérard
de la politique
les cérémonies et déjà c'était nous
parodie donc et senna cesare s'était mes
premiers contacts avec l'asean est ce
que ça a très bien marché ça ça a été
appelé par on a été appelé par paris
première assez vite et on a fait de la
scène très vite et c'était mon premier
contact avec la scène moi la première
fois que j'ai joué un sketch devant des
gens on a été au splendid en direct
devant 400 personnes à saint jean au cp
vers saint jean au cp non mais c'est
bien facile ça s'est mieux passé au
splendid les haut garonnais mais c'était
très étrange parce que d'habitude un
humoriste quand il découvre la première
scène c'est une scène ouverte devant dix
personnes et où dans une cave à paris
oui c'est moi j'ai commencé tout de
suite dans le grand bain par le grand
par le très grand bain mais 3e 4e scène
c'était mille personnes rien et après me
réhabitue de me découvrir les petites
salles les petites scènes les toutes
petites ambiance quand j'ai commencé le
one man show où là pour le coup il faut
rodez il faut tester il faut commencer
petit ça a été un réapprentissage je
suis reparti de zéro
voilà et l or juste avant vous êtes
aussi auteur pour nico est là où nicolas
canteloup avec deux autres auteurs tels
que philippe caverivière et laurent
vassilian d'accord donc en ce moment
c'est sûrement ce matin sur europe 1
tous les maths et marc curiosité moi
j'aimerais savoir comment on travaille
concrètement quand on est auteur de
canteloup à bas tous les jours on
regarde la presse l'actuel matin c'est
ça avait l'air très tôt moi je me lève
tôt pour écouter la radio 2
du jour nous voulons voir un peu ce qui
a été conservé quand je ne le sait pas
parce qu on se relaie pour savoir
exactement ce qui est le matin et mais
en règle générale j'écoute la radio j la
presse je fais ma revue de presse
personnel le matin j'écris l'après-midi
et j'envoie le soir à laurent et
philippe et après laurent et philippe
discuté avec nicolas de quay ce qu'on
garde caisse comprend comment on lisse
l'accord qui fait quoi et après nicolas
le matin appel soit laurent soit
philippe soit moi pour pour décider de
2,2 des derniers ajustements et des
cordes mais très tôt à la radio le matin
mais c'est très hiérarchisée voilà il ya
aléas il y en a un qui est là depuis 15
ans l'autre depuis dix ans et moi je
suis petit dernier depuis cinq ans et
quand même cinq ans oui oui mais bon
enfin voila je suis je suis très grand
sens avec ma troisième place
c'est une bonne gymnastique cs lewis
apprend beaucoup de choses moi ça m'a
pris l'efficacité et laurent et philippe
sont quand même les deux meilleurs
auteurs de paris c'est à dire que je
bosse avec deux génies et ça m'a appris
on est énormément de choses j'ai
beaucoup plus appris avec eux en cinq
ans que j'ai pris tous les autres en
disant mais quand ça fait quinze ans que
j'écris et non jeu j'ai eu une chance
inouïe de travailler comme ça pour nico
parce que en plus par rapport aux autres
humoristes il a un avantage énorme c'est
que c'est un imitateur donc j 60
personnages à disposition pas un pet la
palette est large la palette est large
dont je veux m'amuser sur plein de
registre je peux faire plein de choses
différents sens que ça va ça va payer un
problème qui va le faire il peut le
faire il a les capacités pour il à
l'envi pour il a le talent pour est
d'accord donc je peux faire assez parlé
à nicolas canteloup maintenant reparlons
de vous saluer vous plaît comment est
venue cette idée de spectacle
il ya longtemps vous êtes dessus ça fait
cinq ans que je caresse l'idée de faire
ce spectacle je sentais que les gérards
moi j'arrivais au bout de ce que je
pouvais en c'est fini cet outil non ça
continue
une fois une fois pas enfin les gérard
du cinéma se sont arrêtés les gérard de
la politique sont arrêtés moi j'avais
plus le jus pour faire un spectacle
une fois tous les six mois et le joué
qu'une fois d'accord je voulais un
spectacle j'en avais écrit 15 des gérard
je voulais un spectacle que je puisse
jouer plus sûres et durables sur la
durée un zèle hectares dont et l'idée de
général de ce spectacle c'est un
humoriste qui décide de faire son
premier one man show ouais pour avoir
une carrière hollywoodienne comme du
jardin comme omar sy comme dany boon
comme marion cotillard
ça c'est le rêve du jeune humoriste
c'est le rêve du jeune humoriste est
d'ailleurs le spectacle s'appelle
comment il s'appelle arnaud deux manches
le nouveau de chance n est guère parce
que mon personnage a envie d'être héros
de films d'action c'est très précis le
récit oui c'est au vice et ce qu'il veut
mais c est ben si on ne regardait un
extrait déjà pourquoi pas et puis un
oscar à l'ennemi moi je m'en fous c'est
hollywood qui m'intéresse est aux
confins omar cissé part à essayer des
petites salles en france service après
vente des émissions ça et puis un jour
j'ai lu ça et voilà le gars il pousse un
hémiplégique dans un fauteuil roulant et
par le lendemain il joue dans x-men
x-men voit c'qu'on la classe pas de bol
le héros de x men le professeur xavier
c'est aussi un type en fauteuil roulant
mais c'est que tu peux faire une
carrière avec ça là il ya un biopic de
schumacher qui va se tourner alors il
faut aller vous voir pour vous parce que
c'est drôle
enfin j'espère bien et pour l'instant ça
marche mais pour la masse les les salles
sont pleines et ça rigole tout le long
donc voilà et puis ce qui est assez
rigolo et même touchant c'est que vous
n'hésitez pas à vous mettre en scène un
peu dans des galères oui il fait des
publicités par exemple cette fameuse
publicité en fait je fais le
grandeur et décadence du mythique bien
voilà il se rêve à hollywood d'eau qui
raconte tout ce qu'il a envie de faire à
hollywood et en même temps il fait des
publicités ben là c'est une publicité
pour coeur de lyon par exemple au fond
où il explique qu'il a qu'à demander à
tous contents le camembert par richard
c'est mieux quand même
et voilà donc il est tout content et il
explique que c'est son premier casting
et qu'il attend la réponse est donc il
fait une pub pour du fromage en
expliquant que c'est comme rambo quoi
pour gagner la guerre il faut devenir la
guerre pour jouer un camembert faut
devenir un camembert et vous fait râler
je fais le cam en de la preuve vous
allez reporter le rôle bagelet à la fin
oui mais pas le dire moi c'est une des
surprises du spectacle mais c'est bon
c'est pas bien mais le voilà tout le
spectacle c'est ce que je fais comme
comédien en france pour manger et ce que
je rêve de faire avaler voilà il ya un
parallèle en parallèle entre les deux
entretiens entre le cinéma français est
le cinéma américain et prévisions on
comprend aussi pourquoi il a ça dans la
tête c'est à dire que moi je viens de
versailles mans personnage vient de
versailles et c'est une ville qui a
produit énormément d'artistes mais qui a
les yeux de chimène pour les
scientifiques et les polytechniciens et
c'est aussi un truc dire c'est à dire
que moi quand j'étais à saint jean de
béthune par exemple
on était en été 15 affaire elle ou que
des scientifiques d'une fête il y avait
la baisse cette 9e senti fier c'était
totalement disproportionnée donc il ya
une privilège pour ces gens là et alors
est ce qu on fait un métier très
respectable ce que je fais est un vrai
métier et je gagne même plus que
beaucoup de gens qui étaient en classe
avec moi et qu'on fait des études
scientifiques
ce qui est aussi un indice ça veut dire
qu'on n'est pas juste des branquignols
qui vivent aux crochets de la société
c'est pas vrai les intermittents pour
travailler beaucoup on travaille bien
pouvoir et on participe à une industrie
qui marche vraiment donc c'est aussi le
personnage explique aussi comment est
venue cette vocation là et tout est
parti d'une humiliation un rallye
versaillais qui lui a donné envie de
prouver à tout le monde qu'être artiste
et être fantaisiste être original
s'était pas nécessairement une tare donc
tous les artistes frustré peuvent venir
mais également tous les gens qui ont été
humiliés dans leur adolescence quand
virginie pourquoi on a envie de changer
de vie qui embête et accomplir pas envie
de ne pas nécessairement obéir à leurs
parents mais rfr lula est resté dans le
moule mais faire ce qui leur plaît c'est
pas nécessairement un mauvais choix
quand on est bon dans quelque chose il
faut le faire aimer la meilleure façon
d'exceller c'est ça quand on est
vraiment quelque chose même si ça a
l'air baroque il faut le faire d'accord
donc concrètement là vous êtes sur scène
je suis aux trois bornes de trois bornes
à paris
bâle un métro parmentier tous les
indices ont bondi jusqu'à fin décembre
et on reprendra en janvier normalement
les vendredis et samedis tellement ça
marche ça marche bien ouais je suis
content oui ça mange pas sans vous
laisser une toute petite salle
ouais mais c'est très chaleureuse bien
c'est plateau donc c'est très théâtral
peut faire beaucoup de choses
oui donc voilà c'est une petite salle
laboratoire mais pour l'instant
ça ça roule vraiment hommage bien voilà
si vous avez versailles et que vous avez
envie de voir un autre regard sur votre
ville que celui de d'habitude n'hésitez
pas le voyage vaut le détour
d'accord mais écoutez super descente
donc encore janvier peut-être même après
ont eu l'air aussi par la loi il faut
consulter les chiffres de vente de
billets les relations et on va venir
vous soutenir un bar venez donc avec
grand plaisir parce que vraiment c'est à
la fois drôle et touchant donc bah oui
vous êtes venus mais si je suis venu
bien sûr je sais de quoi je parle tout
de même
merci arnaud vous à très vip à la rabbit
merci